towing the slab and the boogie down
tonight jordan montgomery
see the numbers from last year 10 starts
era was a little bit high a little bit
deceptive only nine walks against 47
strikeouts that's really good over five
to one and we say it's an up and down
year but
that that strikeout the walk ratio was
excellent his fielder independent
pitching his fip was under four so that
tells you maybe he's a little bit of bad
luck
popped up left field coming on
clint frazier and he'll put it away for
the first hour trey mancini stepping up
to the plate trey went three for 12 over
the weekend fly ball
shallow left center going back labor
torres makes the play covered a lot of
ground for the second out
and they have to hit there's a lineup
that's
long and talented and they have to start
hitting and they eventually will the o2
is swung on and hit in the air to left
center drifting over his hicks
and aaron makes the catch and montgomery
has a very easy one two three
and jorge lopez out of puerto rico so
you look at the inflated numbers get
some good games had a couple of games
that really got out of hand eight runs
in his last game another game
against the red sox five run so that
inflated the era he's got good stuff
command sometimes can get a little bit
shaky bounce to second maria's up with
it
and le mayhew retired
here's a 2-1
lined up the middle has a base hit
center field by judge so a big fella at
first base and here is aaron hickson
first pitch swinging
popped up on the left side
mount castle in fair territory makes the
grab two down
now here is giancarlo
who is old for eight
on the season awaiting his first hit one
two
fastball swing gonna miss strike three
lopez powered a 95 mile an hour fastball
by him and judge stranded it first so
here's pedro severino all-star type
catcher
strike three
severino down looking
here is montgomery's pitch hit on the
ground is short
and torres throws to first in time
torres
gary sanchez and jay bruce the three
scheduled hitters for the yankees in the
second 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss it was dropped by
severino but torres looked like he was
going to give himself up now he starts
running down to first the toss goes down
to valencia and the strikeout complete
for out number one on the bottom of the
second they almost at least some people
say they were going to non-tender him as
the 1-2 gets a swing and a miss for
strike three
so he's a strikeout victim so far we've
seen lopez come in the zone with his
fastball here's montgomery's 0-2
swing and a miss
grace
down on strikes
one thing monty does very well
is his mechanics
are very much under control kind of a
slide step pick it up put it down just a
little bit but his head stays so still
swing and a miss
he goes down on strikes two-way
the key to a good change-up is arm
action and deception you do it like that
from the same release point and good arm
speed and that's how you get hitters to
swing over the top effectiveness of your
players here is the one two
struck a mouse swinging breaking ball
down and away great breaking ball
last two strikeouts on that curveball
payoff pitch
swing and a miss he's fooled on the
fastball from lopez the strikeout ends
the inning three complete and no score
nothing nothing as we go to the bottom
of the fourth inning aaron judge
will lead it off there's the 2-0
and the pitch is hit high in the air to
right backwards mckenna on the track
he's at the wall she's gone
it's judgment day
aaron judge hits his first home run of
the year to give the yankees the lead
all rise
here
comes the judge
so home run number one
for judges 18th home run in 53 games
against the orioles sanchez now feeds on
fastballs because last year he was the
only hitter in all of major league
baseball to see
at least one center-cut fastball and not
record a hit off of it
0-2 threw it by him at 95 sanchez down
on strikes for the second time
35 strikes 24 balls
and bruce works a walk to start the
fifth three one
and a walk to where mayhew when that
puts runners on first and second
and the bases are loaded as judge walks
right hand is sean armstrong is on base
is loaded two out one nothing yanks
bottom of the fifth kicks that's ball
four that forces it around it's two
nothing yankees as michelle will touch
up it's an rbi for hicks so ashela
scores and everyone moves up and here is
stanton
driven deep to left center field there
it goes
monster grand slam for stanton and the
yankees lead six nothing
471
feet
non-demetica
that ball sure travel far
mancini the play with an 02 count
swing and a miss
mancini down on strikes
and here is the one two
struck cam out swinging
strikeout number seven
for montgomery
and montgomery has good pitches and
obviously he's throwing strikes but what
he's also doing is varying his pitches
he's behind two and one
the mayhew lines up base it to right
field great inside out swing bruce
scores they'll hold her shella
now it's a base hit and an rbi for dj la
mayhew and the yankees now take a seven
nothing lead how would you like to be
mac
serola this is his big league debut and
he's coming into a game at yankee
stadium with the bases loaded and aaron
judge coming up
can't pull one down
got our big pitch so throw that baseball
out yeah well did you get it did you get
a picture of that buddy
goes both ways
right down the middle but knee high
i got a feeling probably yeah you know
excuse me i i figured that aaron judge
says no way in a world he's going to
throw me eight straight fastballs
popped him up
aleka now gives way to maria hang on wow
crashes that's gotta hurt him into the
wall looks like he's okay and how do you
do max a roller
faces loaded jam he got out of it way to
go kid peralta's chapman to get some
work first time he'll pitch this year
see what he did last season
could not hold up
and he is down on strikes
the o2
swing and a miss
there's the splitter
tumbling dice
what's it's going to be a one-two
and valenca swings and misses strike
three ball game over yankees win the
yankees win
and even their record at two and two the
pitching obviously was great no runs
four hits stanton had a grand slam and
judge had a solo shot